this is some street art that someone
took pictures of and there we go
uh in dc today and then i saw it on
twitter and
within an hour or two i don't remember
what uh reported that he saw some woman
tearing them down
which is you know really unfortunate but
uh here we go we got four pieces of of
street art that showed up in dc
uh for those listening and not watching
we've got biden holding an uh
a mallet and these are all sort of
soviet-style very soviet soviet art
style um
a mallet that says osha on it comply and
he's and he's barking comply comply
uh we have
uh
biden biden yeah that is biden isn't it
uh with needles coming out of his head
and
red masked kids looking up at the sky
and it says good kids are compliant kids
again all of these uh folder uh posters
are soviet art style
um
biden sitting in a chair holding what is
that an artichoke uh is that a
coronavirus i don't know what that is oh
i think it must be i can't see it from
here very well yeah it's like a
carnivirus that's red and his glasses
are red
um and there's masked people behind him
and it says mandate segregate subjugate
and then finally this is maybe my
favorite
we have father fauci with a halo of
an atomic symbol holding a very large
needle and it says trust the scientism
[Laughter]
uh so
those are
fabulous that is what art is supposed to
do that is not the only thing art is
supposed to do but that is one of the
things that art is supposed to be able
to do
and we have a whole lot i mean this and
it's you know it's super meta of course
because it's playing on actual
propaganda and revealing
how
propaganda-ist so much of our modern
messaging is
but you know the fact that within hours
there was someone tearing it down
reveals that this is kind of
metaphorically anamorphic that you can't
see this
as
meta propaganda as commenting on the
propaganda that we are living through
right now unless you're standing in a
particular place you can't see it as
anything but and i'm i'm not going to
play the video that he took of her of
his conversation with her about why she
was tearing them down
but she says it's bad for public health
and you know this is misinformation and
you know all the usual stuff that if
you've got
you know if you've got
if you've got father fauci in your head
and you really think that that's who he
is and he deserves the atomic halo
then um then this is offensive to you
and it feels dangerous
and if you move
really not that far just like not that
far
to the left or the right or the front of
the back or you like levitate something
just like move a little bit
and you will see something very very
different
yeah
i must say i i'm disturbed by how little
art is being used you know as we are
fishing into
multiple non-overlapping societies the
absence of art at that interface is very
disturbing now i have a little
confession
which is that
i
am very much in favor of this mode
from the other side as well
and i remember as a much younger person
back when evangelism was battling
darwinism
i remember
admiring a kind of both sides of an arms
race
right so you had the jesus fish which
had nothing to do with darwin
particularly but it was a proudly
displayed symbol
and
then
the darwinists
put out a jesus fish that said
instead of saying well it was it was
instead of saying jesus in in greek it
said darwin and the fish had legs right
yep um you know poking fun at the
creationists
and then the creationists came back with
a symbol where it was the jesus fish
eating the darwin fish
and i thought you know i like both sides
of this i understand we're having an
argument i definitely you know the fish
with the legs
i mean you know this is actually even
before we were at michigan uh when phil
gingrich the paleontologist came back
with his
early spectacular finds of
whales with legs yeah right
from pakistan i think yeah and he was
there he was at umz as we were yeah he
was so it was you know he came back and
it was this spectacular news so anyway
you know the idea of fish with legs or
whatever yeah that's
surprisingly on target right it's not
it's not just glib it's actually
sometimes how this works and
um but anyway i like the idea of people
who can be good-natured about their
differences and they you know i sort of
believe that in the end the better art
will win
right um you know i don't believe that
for any
deep reason but i think the point is one
side is more vulnerable because its
explanation is worse and so well this
reminds me of something that you've
pointed out often uh which is i i maybe
you're not the first to have pointed out
i've also heard it in other corners but
um you know a movement that doesn't
tolerate laughter or a movement in which
there is no laughter um is not what it
seems and
probably can't last although
although the the the walkery the
safetyism and the woke the walkery seem
to be a mostly laughter free movement
and they they're pretty damn persistent
yeah laughter free and surprisingly tone
deaf including the medically woke very
you know very much more about fear than
laughter you know laughter is probably
dangerous because it spews droplets or
something yeah yeah no
and you know the
no kidding that they want to shut down
comedians right right right because the
point is they just don't have they don't
have an argument that can go up against
um being rightly mocked
you know i mean that that's the thing
that's what it's for it's what mockery
is yeah and that's what those posters
are yeah yeah and you know at the same
time i did not before uh before our
stream have time to put together a
list of these things where there's a
bunch of just jaw-dropping authoritarian
moves being made
in i think in germany i saw that
telegram
is they're contemplating banning
telegram because
people who are skeptical of vaccines are
using it to talk to each other
right now
i am i'm sure they get tired in germany
of being the example of um you know how
could it be them given what they just
what they what they went through the two
generations ago but seriously germany
like how could it be you right
i will say i am old enough to remember
when a move like that could never have
happened in the west two years ago
[Music]